can you all stand in a straight line we
can't stand in a straight line
true
[Music]
line it was difficult for me to come
out I'm surprised that a lot of us are
on this side of the spectrum there was
no coming out for me in my generation
because I came up in a very Christian
family and uh didn't have a lot of lgbtq
folks around me that were examples of
living freely as themselves and so there
was no closet for me to come out of I
was just expected to not be me my
difficulty was really telling my four
children and letting them know that you
know their dad had always felt that he
was female and my daughter kind of
rejected me for a long time and uh that
that was very painful but was able to
get through that my experience is
similar to yours but I'm here at
somewhat agree because my family is
Muslim and then my mother left that
faith and became born again Christian
and it's because she told me when I came
out to her your walk is your walk and
that helped me come out and and just be
me because it was always there when I
meet young people sometimes you'll see
them and they may not be there yet but
they recognize something and I had that
happen with a friend's child who now
identifies as non-binary and the first
time I met them I looked at them and I
said hi my name's Abby my pronouns are
they them theirs how would you like me
to address you and their eyes lit up
because it was the first time they felt
seen I want them to see me and know that
you're going to be okay you have family
there you have Community there the
reason it was difficult is because I was
pulled out of the closet when I was 17
and even though I had a relationship
with my first girlfriend and we knew we
liked each other and we knew that we
were exploring something that was really
new that was our secret and when the
this popular kid at school found a note
that I wrote to her and spread all over
the school that's when the coming out or
the pulling out happened and that was a
an irely traumatic process I had to now
process liking a girl but now I am
exposed to the entire school I was
incredibly privileged to grow up in a
really rather liberal Town um my
principal was openly
gay I also had a friend who was already
out and was was there by my side when I
was coming out to people and of course
there was you know emotional turmoil and
whatnot you know I first came out as a
gay man which was easier that than
coming out as like a a transfem non
person um but even then like I found
myself like able to um create a safe
bubble my experience was was difficult
because I grew up in a very Catholic
Family um in the midwest in St Louis um
as a black Trans fim as well like I
didn't have the language or anyone to
look to around me so I too like you came
out as a gay male um when I was like 13
and my family was just not having it I
always knew that was a woman but again
not having the language at the time and
not being supported with that language
and also not seeing people around me
that like felt like me or looked like me
was very difficult I'm in the middle
because coming out 27 years ago in the
South you know don't ask don't tell was
the law of the land samesex relations
were still criminalized in many US
states there was no marriage equality it
was hard my family my parents didn't
accept me right away but I always knew
there was nothing wrong with me so for
that reason coming out was joyful I have
always felt accepted by the lgbtqia plus
community so for me I came out as a
black gay man with a lot of sugar in our
tank didn't know what non-binary was
heard what non-binary was finally felt
good Within Myself and I find the most
attacks as a non-binary person for me
has been from gay men and trans women
wow who actually think you know you're
non-binary so you don't really exist in
the trans world you don't exist in the
gay world but um I'm here yeah then when
we think about like intersectionality
like you know black white all of that
like that also plays a factor too as a
black person that grew up in St Louis
and like our our scene there is majority
CIS white gay men um who also just look
at black people of like why are you here
I don't think that we talk about the
racism within our own Community often
enough so growing up in South Texas and
finding my you know first gay clubs to
go to it's like you're okay to be here
as a lesbian but you're not okay to be
here as
black I can't separate I can't divide
those things and speaking of racism and
privilege I don't think it's a
coincidence that there's a couple of not
speaking for you Katherine but I think
that some of our privilege as white
people may be why we're standing part of
the reason why we're standing over here
I think we have our issues within the
lgbtqi community especially the trans
community because a lot of us have dealt
with such trauma and and have
internalized that and sometimes take it
out on other people in the community
which is unfortunate but I've always
been accepted as who I am and that's
because you can't tell me who I am I
know who I am if you want to make me
someone else that's your problem not
mine abely I did transition in the mid
80s and into the '90s but had to
detransition because had lost my job and
I couldn't find another job so I went
back to being my male self developed my
career again and continued on in about
2013 or 2011 actually um I had a
near-death experience and found out that
I really should get on with my life as
Catherine I don't always correct
homophobic or transphobic
comments I don't wait I don't always I
often get an influx of of hate comments
and you know I used to engage and I
realize it just takes your energy away
and so I just try to focus on my
immediate physical reality I tell the
corers do not look at the comments and
they'll look at the comments and they'll
get so upset and so hurt and I'm like
screw those people we don't even know
who they are there's this time about a
few weeks ago I took my twins my
9-year-old twins to the pediatrician and
I was signing on the the forums and what
did the forums say mom and dad and I was
clear to the doctor when I went into the
room with the doctor I said you know
London and Duke have two moms and your
form doesn't account for that but then I
went to the front desk as I was signing
out and said you know to the the office
manager this needs to be changed and I
scratched it out like there's probably a
little bit of anger and frustration
scratching it out like I was like this
really needs to be changed because it's
very frustrating it's exhausting it
takes energy as someone who grew up in
the Midwest and South you know grew up
with a lot of male cousins I was always
like fighting um you know I was very
feminine so I always had to protect
myself then you know as I transitioned
and got older um I found myself in a lot
of abusive relationships unfortunately
moving through that I'm always on high
alert and always feel the need to
protect myself so if I hear something
I'm always like correcting someone but I
I also understand that I'm trying to get
out of that because that is really
rooted in survival right I feel like I
can't let it go um it's too much of the
letting it go that's gotten us to where
we are already Yes you almost feel kind
of Parental in a way you know you need
to you need to correct this person you
need to change their thinking and if
they keep folks are allowed to say
things and do things and nothing gets
said you know how can I call myself an
advocate for social justice if when I
hear these things going on I simply
don't say anything brands that support
the lgbtqia plus Community do so with
the best
intentions I
didn't I think that brands that are very
transactional and so they'll only call
US during pride month and then we talk
about the so what about the post pride
month support like what does that look
like and so I think that many Brands um
have not figured out how to not be
transactional in their interactions with
us like this is like a relationship
y'all that's what I like tell them you
know not like pick us up when you're
ready for us because it makes you look
good for pride month and then throw us
back out whenever like we're suffering
day in and day out we need you January
through December not just June we've
been fortunate with our course to work
with some amazing brands that have been
very supportive but then there are those
that they know they're going to call you
during as we said pride month but I am
hopeful that a lot of Corporations
because we're all part of these
corporations now but they have to look
within their corporate structure and
really make the necessary changes to be
um more supportive to the lgbtq plus and
and B pop communities year round you
know coming to us in June we're well you
know what we're booked I'm already
booked for next year book busy and
blessed so you know now it comes down to
which one of those sponsors are going to
help us out the most and then we might
get them a spot I've done a lot of like
Pride um sponsorships with Brands and
there are a lot of Brands who are
incredibly intentional like care with
pride makes sure that their messaging
and their branding like isn't just
performative that the folks that they're
representing like are actually being
supported and they check in with you
it's not just hey here's a few dollars
and promote us they actually genuinely
check in with you throughout the year
and you know I'm here thanks to them
they helped us install security cameras
after our mural was vandalized a few
years ago and ironically two weeks ago
we were vandalized with swastikas and
and um just hateful rhetoric and we
actually had the security system and we
were able to turn that over to the
Orlando Police Department and the person
has since been arrested there are a lot
of companies and a lot of people who
aren't paying attention to what's
happening outside the US and it's really
rare to find a company that cares so
much and is paying attention to what's
happening to lgbtq people around the
world is willing to support us
financially and is willing to send us
care packages for the activists that we
work with oh hello it's me L thanks so
much for tuning in to this special
Jubilee episode of spectrum I wouldn't
be here In This Very Room sharing my
perspective with these incredible
leaders if it weren't for care with
pride okay but wait what is care with
pride it's an employee Le cross brand
initiative that is dedicated to openly
supporting love equality and care for
all individuals within the lgbtqia plus
Community since 2011 care with pride has
donated over .5 million to nonprofit
groups including a wide variety of local
and Regional organizations making
positive Grassroots impacts on the
community advancing equality takes a
community on all fronts and this
initiative is here to stand with and by
lgbtqia plus people check out the link
in the description to learn more okay
back to the episode certain people in
the lgbtqia plus Community are given
more of a voice than
others
I want to hear what you say well I'm the
only one that's not strongly
agreeing and and the reason for that is
we take responsibility to use our own
voice and if you let somebody else take
your voice that's kind of on you in a
way gu you know the hierarchy is gay men
right exactly gay white men
specifically and then there's the rest
of us and that's kind of how I feel why
does somebody always have to be at the
bottom yeah why does somebody always
have to be at the top absolutely why is
somebody always in the middle yeah why
can't we all have parity and Equity
across all of our voices exactly for me
to be the first black person to lead an
organization in 44 years and I'm Not The
Only One For The First Time in history
there's six black leaders black queer
leaders who are leading National
organizations so for me other folks were
given gay white men were given a voice
they were given a seat at the table and
we were not so that strong voice in
leadership was not heard from anyone who
looked like me and and it for an
organization to take four decades to
realize that it's time to create space
for other people at the table that that
parody needs to be actually something
that we think about it's happening now
and it has not been happening for long
enough my wife and I had challenges when
we were trying to create our family it
was a nightmare and we almost gave up
and many lgbtq plus people do give up on
their dream of becoming parents for me
now that I have a family I want anyone
to who wants a family to have that
family and I want to be a part of that
journey and help remove barriers for
them so they can create that speaking of
people who are not heard I've since I
work internationally I can just say that
queer activists and queer people who
live outside of the US outside of
Western Europe are oftentimes largely
invisible and they're not really
supported and so for me one of the
things I'm passionate about is passing
the mic to them lifting up their voices
making sure people see that queer people
are literally everywhere on this planet
and the other thing is as a CIS person
just passing the mic to trans people or
when I have a platform making sure that
I'm talking about trans rights trans
issues that's the thing that I am so
passionate about and I wish other people
assist people in our community would
give up that power we're literally
elbowing each other we're elbowing each
other to get a seat at the table and
it's like that's not how it works I tell
people when they do that I'm like do you
want to be free or not because if you're
worried about power and you won't give
that mic to someone else and you don't
want to be free it's more important to
have allies out outside than inside the
community I think it starts with us yes
and if we can't stand up for not only
ourselves but our siblings in our own
Community then we're lost I think we
have to have to be there for each other
within our community that said we're
never going to see the change we want to
see in the world if we don't get more
allies to join us I often get called out
in the trans Community as a music group
bringing in an ally to work with us but
I'm like we need that I think it's kind
of a big thing for us to reach out and
bring them in as much as they need to
reach back I think whether we want to
admit it or not they are in spaces that
we're not and sometimes their voices are
going to be listened to before they
listen to our voices people show their
true colors too when we're not around so
a lot of times like it is it is then
that they need to know that they are not
safe to to express that when we around
because if they are then they just won't
invite us the lgbtqia plus movement is
stronger now than ever
before I think it's stronger but this is
where my intersectionality runs in into
play it's just like yeah it's kind of
strong but then you know you walk into
the room and there's still like as my
grandmother said this brown skin is not
going anywhere so I bring this with me
everywhere and I would love for my queer
siblings to really see that and see all
of this as one not just as a part of if
I'm in that click enough what really
gives me hope is how much it's growing
and how vibrant it is and from the
international perspective with outright
we see activists in literally almost
every country on the planet so it's
incredibly hopeful to think about how
much progress we've made and I think we
really have an opportunity to radically
accelerate social legal change for
everyone in our community because of the
strength of the activists and Advocates
and allies who are on the ground who are
doing the work and who aren't going to
give up being in the social media space
I see that social media has given us the
ability to connect in a way that we
never have been before and be able to
see our experience in each other and to
grow more secure in our lived experience
by witnessing someone else living freely
in theirs I do believe that that
connection is what is scaring
folks into trying to create legislation
against us so I do believe that while we
are at risk perhaps more than ever we it
that is a sign of us being stronger and
more connected than ever I think we have
a lot of young soldiers coming up behind
us young young folks young Fighters that
are willing to take up the Baton and are
brave and courageous and just I admire
them completely and so you know it's one
of the reasons why I keep doing this
work cuz know that the generations
coming behind us they should have a much
better time of life than we did a local
school board in the area where I live in
the South Bay of Los Angeles the
Schoolboard chair wanted to ban a book
because it had a trans character in it
so a group of us I belong to P flag we
all went up to the board meeting to say
our our thoughts I didn't have to the
young students in that group stood up
and eloquently told the school board
if you ban that book more people are
going to read it number one number two
you can't tell me who I am I know who I
am to hear these younger people and
that's what gives me the greatest hope
as the younger generation is coming
together and saying we're just who we
are if we're getting to a point where
the younger ones are going to they look
at us and they're like we don't care
what your orientation is we don't care
about your gender expansion what we care
about is what are you doing in my Planet
what are you leaving me with you have
children what are leaving them with I
mean that's what gives me hope is that
they are going to come up and soon this
is all going to be pushed aside they
can't stop us it's a movement you know
they can knock us down every year with
Tor and other atrocities in our
community but we rise up and we rise up
and we rise up meeting everyone here
today is like very empowering like being
surrounded by so much love and care is
really important it really like drives
the passion and the movement forward 1 2
3 look at
us you have
more friends than you
know some who surround you some you are
destined to meet you'll have
more love in your life don't let go
give it
time take it
slow those who love you the most many
more time to
grow it's going to be
okay you have more friends than you
[Music]
know oh my goodness